hey guys Ryan is here so everyone's been
asking me to check out this video I
haven't seen it we'll say up front
Sally has seen it but she loved it so
much she [ __ ] begged me to watch this
yeah she's like Ryan I'll show you my
tits I'm like I don't care to see your
tits Ali which part anyway yes God is an
impersonation of Robin Williams Walt :
Wilson your immenseness humans they're
strange they're things called pets a
crew and they pee and they love them
nano nano being naked is the only way
you can enjoy it
Jack have you ever heard of the story in
the Fisher King lucky whether to bring
you this yo the name is baddy a gun
right batting my logic is about it no
you got fantasize the woman yes dance
just watching a movie
hey weebo I wanted to be a father daddy
Oh Teddy that's my happy thought pan the
Avenger is back with BOM oh man
bangerang
I don't know someday I wanna fight
spinach sterile Whittle do you remember
a game called Jumanji it's me Alan your
turn
hi I'm Scott I'm your dad oh that's firm
handshake we have the same Hey look a
world that's right if you lean in you
can hear them say it it's like there's
no different President of the United
States
remember gentleman walk softly and carry
a big stick smile my boy hi
it's my first day I'm Jeff I've got
chest hair you know even the faces
everybody always picking on me come on
don't bother me I don't have a radio get
your news somewhere else
god I hope it's not Miranda no
definitely dear
oh nothing like a snow come on in
Phoenix all right let's talk about your
medical records you've said something
and you survived three come on will tell
me what you want to do with your life I
don't know say anything say you want to
see a better girl always a winner in my
book I want to work with this guy that
was incredible that was one of the most
impressive things I've seen I've seen a
lot of like impression videos
impersonation videos this guy not only
nails down like Robin Williams he nails
down the characters to that Robin
Williams has played all the movies and
all the lines yeah like not only can he
impersonate you know one person but also
the characters that person is darn he
looks so much like him though because
it's one thing like you can do a really
good impression you have a really good
Johnny Depp impression but you don't
look like you know you really like him
yeah he also got the facial expressions
now I'm like to the T that was crazy
like you hear the voice and you're like
that is that it has to be like Doug
know what's amazing to me is that he'll
do voices that Robin Williams was doing
voices of you know like the French
accent or like the enthusiasm or Juanita
oh yeah I was literally watching the
birdcage yesterday know that is one of
my favorite Robin Williams performances
seeing a movie yesterday and then seeing
it like from an impersonation point of
view like just amplifies how real this
thing felt yeah when I first saw this
guy actually I saw one of his vines I
started crying actually because it was
right it was right around the time when
it was reported that Robin Williams had
passed people don't understand how you
can miss someone or feel the sorrow for
someone that you've never met before if
they die or if something happens to me
you can I mean he was a part of our
lives just as much as like you know a
family member is because you see them
all the time you see him all the time in
the movies and anything that that
brought you up like not even just like
it just like a nanny or something if
you're watching movies and they help you
through your life and an actor helps you
through your life just from their
performances they are a part of your
life so if anyone ever tells you like
you're stupid for being upset because
someone like Robin Williams passed away
like don't feel stupid because they
helped us grow up you think about a
movie like patch Adams and there's no
one else that was perfectly kept no one
else could have done that because if
there's any one that understood the gift
of laughter it was him in every movie
even when he was like taking on a more
serious role he always had a sense of
sincerity yeah you could say he's
beautiful you just like believed
everything and like he truly felt that
to me is what makes the best actor is
when you know they're not just saying
lines they're feeling what they're
saying and he was that type of actor
yeah this guy definitely definitely did
Robin Williams son justice so thank you
for that
this channel we want to make it more of
a drama so we're we're transitioning
listen if you guys are new to the
channel it's okay you could subscribe
and Sally one of my best friends right
here she has a channel too you can check
it out it's awesome
you know what we want to stay connected
so you can follow us on Facebook
Instagram and Twitter
mm-hmm where it's just about hey first
of all your subscribers
why and seen